welcome to this video GDC okay let's do
a fringe again last one worked out
really nicely okay the my winner vs
special with b6 this time I really get
it on the board okay I get this traded
I'm always always glad hmm the bishop on
a six-day can take with the pawn that's
true and it does not mean that this is
necessarily a great structure I still
have ideas with the c5 later it looks a
bit strange because well my night is is
blocking is blocking the sea porn but i
still have ideas to move it Knight a5
then c5 those kind of ideas are possible
okay I'm not moving the king yet yeah
maybe no maybe no castles why it's not
not necessary really I can try to go for
c5 hmm
it's going on the sea fire Joe it's hard
to never cancel here hit this position
yeah but c5 is sister debatable via
details be takes it opens up the beef
I'll you know yeah but okay maybe I need
some better preparation maybe it is an
idea to get in something like night be
seven then see 50 okay he's just he is
doing stuff surprisingly
I that it didn't really expect but not
saying that it is bad i just have just
didn't expected yeah hmm this I don't
really know this is this is this any
good I mean if it takes on b6 this is
just a nice structure of the two bonds d
493 are there really any helpful champ d
for especially as we can this Bishop
happens p is worse and his bishop on a
little bit um yeah Knight a5 over yeah I
guess so yeah maybe you can just go
Quincy three sorry kid here I can use
the the rook I think
b5 now yeah I guess which is
strategically very desirable cut the
apron the passer and this Bishop now
really is looking at our head points d
falsify those bones okay maybe I can now
start an invasion Quincy eight wait g4 I
can always go to e7 ready okay so Quincy
eight is good
my main intention is to play Queen B 7
rugby three cream be fire them piling up
on the d3 pawn and he still has to take
care about d for all the time rook rook
be three now hmm not sure about it hindu
queen a one now that that's very
complicated let's just keep it simple
ninety-seven is just keeping a very nice
edge for black yeah of course check look
trade I love it hmm ok then I'm taking
their I do mind that at all I've got
this pawn and it's an exceptionally good
structure really everything's completely
sound and protected him very nice ok but
what now aged five this is also
interesting just playing for queen bee
three
yeah but queen bee three is probably not
a winning probably not h5 h3 don't get
it to f5 so there any way to improve
these seven night I just really want a
good good good place for it I don't see
okay I see something else I can go to a
74 night to be five it's probably not
bad yeah I was wondering about GFI if
the whole time but he never went for
that no 95 95 is nicer it detects deform
two times and supports the march of the
a pond now three that's very good
yeah yeah just get just improve slowly
don't rush even even the King i can
improve a little bit why this is really
not in a position to do anything it's
almost stalemated him yeah Queenie one
would be cool to get in like 94 then but
I can just improve the crew prove this
first and then see what's what's
happening one point is of the king is
that I possibly have Quincy three or
just the trade now or something better
90 time when I it takes check on you
while it's not not enough surprisingly
okay
what I'm doing is I'm preparing this
move here check
and now the king is ready to invade
yeah that's all nice he's got one second
that's helpful I'm not totally sure how
to win it looks it looks fantastic of
course but I don't see how to win maybe
there is no one night before I'm sorry
yeah of course night before is that is
the way to go took me took me a while to
see that and then I get to be three
white for Phase long time yeah like this
I'm sorry left room like this and and
King to be three yeah it all doesn't
have us a nice nice game that was fun to
play yeah round here I'm certainly okay
but it's nothing to do special but it
got problematic right after this because
now I'm basically playing with an extra
pawn the a pond and this is just so nice
those nights our position to pressurize
the pawn on d4 white is really he's a
bit tied down really very tough to play
and it's very likely that I've never had
something more concrete I wanted to to
play it like super safe yeah just keep
everything as is and improved to the
utmost i think it was it was okay the
King coming over this is the kind of
plan where the human is still a little
bit better sometimes than the machine
and it's kind of long this long long
maneuvers yeah hippie black is really
winning I'm invading with with
everything and now night before King b3
is come here as a nice game yeah hope
you liked it thanks for watching